we're a trending topic so it's relevant
to speak on because it's interesting
it's fascinating I am fascinated by hoes
I'll say it I'm absolutely fascinated by
the way the whole mind works the way the
whole Hive works I'm fascinated I cover
it on my show it is trending when Emma
gets up and does a video and says
something like you know I'm it's cheap
to be divorced before you're 30. it is
absolutely fascinating to see how
someone's Minds can be so warped you
know in the same way that I think it's
it's fascinating When anybody does
anything crazy or says anything crazy
and I cover it on my podcast you know I
am not knocking it at all I just tell
people what the facts are you can choose
this lifestyle and here is where you are
99.9 likely to lead in your life right
you are probably not destined for
marriage you're not probably not
destined for sale relationship men are
gonna not want this long term you can
say it a thousand times you can have a
thousand cultural examples and women's
still got to go out there and be hoes
you know because they're about they
money and about a cardi B song or
whatever it is so yes I think it is
fascinating I three
I agree with Candace here you know it
really is fast like
I I see you know women used to take L's
in peace okay let's not pretend like our
grandmothers our mothers never took an
Ellen dating never never made a poor
decision okay but they were at least
ashamed
and you know there's something
respectable about shame
there's something respectable about it
because at least you know you can admit
all right that wasn't the right decision
but I do I do feel I do feel shame about
it
um but the problem is in modern culture
is that really not only do women not
feel shame we parade our bad decisions
and Market it to the younger women as
good decisions and this is the problem
is you know and we get so much Flack for
just calling water wet the sky is blue
men don't generally like [__]
you know it's better to be more pure
okay so there was a a feminist lady on
Twitter
that was just enraged she was enraged at
Dad's and she said this is why the dads
don't get custody this is why um you
know women are better parents and she
showed a super educational clip from
Jimmy Kimmel let's pull it up can you
name their teachers of course I cannot
what are your daughters birthdays ah why
do you do this to me what about her I
give up any guesses yesterday oh yeah
yesterday
horrible her birthday was yesterday
yes can you name the best friend of each
of your daughters
can you give us the name of their doctor
can you give us the name of their
dentist uh games Dental then
uh what are your daughter's birthdays
yes uh May 28 2009 okay
[Applause]
okay so now this feminist is coming in
and implying that men are bad dads
because they don't know their their kids
birthdays and I just thought how this is
the most out of touch comment I've I've
seen in my life
um you're gonna argue with me that men
are are bad or somehow less the fathers
because they don't know
their kid's birthday I'll tell you
something I I don't even know if my dad
knows my birthday he gets him confused
all the time but that's not guys don't
care about the little stuff that's woman
stuff so again you're measuring a dad
you're measuring a dad being a good dad
based on female standards I mean that's
stuff typically women know and you're
asking men to be women when men men are
men it's so interesting because
it's like they demonize men when they're
spending their their and Jimmy Kimmel
didn't do this but this comment is
demonizing men for spending their
Saturday with their family you know what
what did my dad do my dad would always
go to my basketball games like you know
what's so funny my dad wouldn't know my
birthday but he could tell me how many
points we won by at my sixth grade
basketball game he coached you know what
I mean like you know dads just like
different stuff yeah he doesn't care
about a birthday party and you know what
I gotta say in my fifth grade tournament
we did get gold
not silver we're number one baby